el gobierno francés ha cumplido sus
amenazas los empleados en huelga de este
depósito de exon Mobile tendrán que
volver al trabajo o enfrentarse a
sanciones penales los enfurece porque se
está violando nuestro derecho a la
huelga desde el principio a nuestro
movimiento ha sido Pacífico obviamente
nosotros el ggt en cuanto tengamos estas
demandas presentaremos denuncias a
través de nuestros abogados por el
momento la obligación a trabajar no se
refiere a las actividades de la
refinerías y por tanto a la producción
de combustible
pero el objetivo es permitir el
transporte de la gasolina que ya está
almacenada allí seis de las siete
refinerías seguían cerradas el miércoles
algunas desde hace más de dos semanas
está previsto que el gobierno realice
otra requisiciones en los próximos días
el impacto este conflicto social se ha
alargado y somos conscientes de ello Es
algo insoportable para demasiado
franceses
algunos de los cuales se les impide ir a
trabajar llevar a sus hijos al colegio
mientras las filas en las gasolineras se
alargan en toda Francia en algunos
departamentos los preceptos dan
prioridad a los vehículos de emergencia
y a los cuidadores una medida que no a
todo el mundo le gusta esta es la
tercera estación de servicio en la que
he estado Así que hemos estado luchando
desde esta mañana desde las 7 de la
mañana estoy en la calle ante la
probabilidad de que continúe la escasez
cada vez más sindicatos de las llamadas
profesiones esenciales exigen un acceso
prioritario